[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful moment of calm there as chief
terence monahan of the new york city
police department
kneeled in solidarity with protesters
welcome back to cbs this morning there's
that moment of calm there in new york
and there were other moments across the
country
but unfortunately here here in this city
those positive feelings did not last
into the night there was looting and
clashes
and those marred another day of peaceful
demonstrations in the city
as many ignored a new curfew earlier in
the day we tagged along with monahan and
asked him
about the nypd's response to the
protests so far
what happened in minnesota was an
outrage completely and totally
but 800 000 law enforcement officers
around this country are paying the price
for what that guy did in minnesota can
you understand the anger
that we see over here absolutely i
understand the anger
protest yell scream let your rage out
but don't take your rage out on the
community destroy the businesses
that actually employ members of this
community
after violence erupted over the weekend
chief terence monahan and the nearly 40
thousand officers he oversees
geared up for more protests where is the
line between a peaceful protest and
out of control bottles and rocks thrown
at my cops
windows being broken stars being looted
got no place in american society
but in recent days tempers have flared
and the new york city police department
has faced criticism for how some
officers
have responded you have to look at the
entire incident
you have to look at the rocks being
thrown the injuries to my offices
what happened before what precipitated
that event
knowing that we had a commanding officer
trapped in his car
his last transmission was this may be my
last transmission
dragged out of that car this is what's
going through a cop's mind
as he gets around it as he checked in
with his team yesterday afternoon
things remain peaceful there's a theory
out there
that when you guys armor up and look
like military
that's when they get wild as well they
get more militaristic when you get more
militaristic
no it's usually reactive usually we're
gonna uh suit up
after we say that the the temperature
has gone up okay
if they're yelling and screaming that's
fine but when bottles start coming i
gotta put the helmets on i got to get
the shields out to protect my guys
it's a show of force hard to miss for
protesters like shataja bird
what do you think when you see that i am
devastated i am disgusted we just
want justice for our people the same how
anyone else would
it's all we care for the police say that
they want to
have a light touch de-escalate do you
believe that
i mean you see them behind us right i
came today in flip-flops
ripped jeans in a shirt i have no need
or no desire to want to fight
to once we get pepper sprayed down to
want to be tied but i am prepared
because i will fight for my people by
any means necessary this
is our city monahan says he believes the
vast majority of people causing trouble
are coming from outside new york we have
a lot of encouragement from outside
agitators telling people
to go out and cause mayhem in the city
using i think this movement
for an agenda to end policing throughout
the country an anarchist
agenda you say end policing that's what
they do
all the signs that you see is defund
policing no more police
as monahan watch things unfold from the
ground deputy chief edward mullane had a
different view
from surveillance cameras feeding into a
command center at police headquarters
this is mob mentality this has nothing
to do with peaceful protests
trying to right injustice but these
people walking peacefully down the
street that's not bob mentality is it
well we don't like people walking in the
middle of the street we like the rights
of everybody else who wants to drive in
manhattan
but many americans clearly believe this
is the way to get attention
as they press on for change what role
does
racism play in these outcomes where you
have black men dying at a greater rate
than other populations at the hands of
police i don't believe racism plays a
role
in new york i can only speak for what
i've seen in new york city
and yet you've got these outcomes and if
those protesters heard you say that
racism doesn't play a role
that's why they're here that's why
they're angry they don't think you get
it
i would never say that we are a racist
police department absolutely not have
incidents happened
maybe there was a racist incident
something and that person
has been removed from this agency
absolutely
we all care about the communities we
work in we care
deeply in the minority communities the
cops that work there each and every day
yes you have a problem there that is
obvious to some people but chief members
of the nypd police force at least don't
want to name it
and if you don't name it it can be hard
to solve it it's worth noting gail
and one of the things that complicates
the situation here in new york is that
the majority of officers in the nypd are
minorities themselves it's a majority
minority department
and chief monahan points out that
officers in his department
they do frequently face repercussions
for inappropriate actions if there's a
bad cop they get rid of him he says
about 100 cops every year
are fired chief monahan i thought tony
touched a lot of hearts yesterday when
he knelt down with the protesters and
was hugging and engaging with them but
then on the other hand when people say
that racism isn't the issue or they
don't believe that's the issue it's such
a contradiction and it's so hard to
understand
that's why that's exactly as you point
out why people are in the streets
yeah you can bridge the gulf in part by
taking a knee and joining hands but if
you can't say it along with them it's
hard to move forward
but move forward we must